smile's a story that's intensely
psychological
action but it's also instilled with this
creeping sense of unease i'm seeing
something no one else can see what
happens when you do see it that's
smiling at me but not a friendly smile
it's the worst smile i've ever seen i
wanted to create a film that feels like
an escalating nightmare
before she died
she was smiling
she's faced with witnessing something
that is horrific
the evil in the film uses a smile as a
mask to hide its true intentions
she starts to believe that something
evil may have come into her life
something is threatening me
she's losing touch gross do you hear
yourself in a very real way
this story is just the kind of thing
where you question whether this could
happen in real life and that's why it
sucks you in i really think you should
speak to someone i'm not crazy dealing
with something you can't escape and not
knowing where it's coming from
that's scary
i don't know what it is
but i'm seeing it everywhere how does it
make you feel
what are you
nothing can prepare you for what's gonna
happen
the scares
and the way the camera told the story
this is something that we really haven't
seen before
and it's so scary
this is not real
[Music]
you